what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into Aquaman DC rebirth
is kind of an interesting situation
right now because if I'm being honest
with you guys as much as I love what DC
we Worth is done I'm kind of ready for a
like a fresh influx of new titles like
Shazam or JSA or something because right
now it seems like for the last two or
three years we've just been getting like
stories with the same titles all the
time and I'm kind of getting tired of
reading about Aquaman all the time so I
love what DC's done I don't need to tear
them down at all it's just I think it's
ready for uh you know I think we're
ready for some new blood and and it's I
think it's been long enough but the fact
remains here when it when it comes to
this whole Aquaman thing really this
story begins kind of the the next era of
Aquaman and it seems like it's necessary
for his character really was what's kind
of happened so far is it's largely been
the traditional fare of Aquaman himself
which is to say trying to find a balance
between being the king of Atlantis and
being a superhero on the surface world
which as most people who are reading
Aquaman will tell you that's the core
part of his character it's the nature of
what he of what he does and what he
believes he is a guy that tries to find
a middle ground between the you know
between Atlantis his role as king and
trying to be a superhero on the surface
now if how if being asked to make a
choice if he's if he's basically told
you know do you choose Atlantis or do
you choose the surface world Aquaman
would by and large choose Atlantis
especially in the middle of a crisis but
what this does is it answers the
question in more of a in more of a
unique way and so of course with Aquaman
and Mara basically returning back to
Atlantis proper once they reach the
throne room everybody's gone and that's
not normally what happens the reason for
this is because with Aquaman being gone
a Regents basically placed in his stead
which is to say somebody who essentially
sits on the throne and governs in his
place you know they are basically the
voice of the king while the King's not
there but when he gets here and
everyone's gone it really begins to ask
a few questions the question they begin
to ask is where is everyone at now of
course this is met almost immediately
with the arrival of quorum wrath and the
reason why this is a big deal is because
quorum wrath remember is the leader of
the deluge the deluge of course
basically being the rebel faction within
Atlantis that's been trying to find a
way to topple you know Arthur curry as
king there's not much doing here it's
your standard fare between like the
deluge and and Aquaman and mirror and
that's all that that's really all it is
but with the arrival are really with the
the end of this conflict comes like the
actual members of Atlantis essentially
like the council
of elders and when they arrived here
what they basically say is quorum wrath
is here because they brought him here
and he's been brought here he's
basically been released from prison
because what they're doing is they're
basically saying it's time for Aquaman
to go and it's very interesting because
what's essentially happened is the
kingdom of Aquaman has turned against
Aquaman now really the the kind of big
push that led to this came in the last
couple stories warhead and in HTML but
those aren't really essential stories
this itself is a long time coming it
didn't come out of nowhere
it wasn't like suddenly they turned
against Aquaman they've really just kind
of been raising an eyebrow consistently
and those are the points that are being
made here people basically say look like
as Aquaman your your your role is to be
a king of Atlantis but you're not you're
a king who's almost never here you're a
king who's almost always fighting
alongside the Justice League on the
surface you're a king that makes
yourself look like one of the metahumans
from the surface it's almost as if you
wish you could be one of them as opposed
to being the king of Atlantis and if
you're not really loyal to Atlantis then
we'll just remove you and so at the end
of the day when you start having Aquaman
asking the question even when Mara
starts asking questions you know is this
really going to stand you guys cannot
depose him he's the king even his most
you know even Merc like one of his most
loyal servants says I served the throne
whoever happens to be on the throne is
who I served but I do not serve loyalty
I did not swear fealty to Aquaman I
swore that to the throne and so it's one
of these things where you begin to sort
of look around at the kingdom of
Atlantis and realize it really was all
just sitting on eggshells it really was
Aquaman with no absolute guarantee he
was gonna be king forever and I feel
like this is a great change of pace I
feel like it's a great direction to take
his stories in because we always kind of
knew that about Aquaman I was always
kind of a thought sitting in the back of
your head but it was something that you
never really considered but with Aquaman
kind of being deposed and being pushed
out things brouilly really begin to get
hairy here because in response to this
what the council basically does is they
say we're removing Aquaman and we're
replacing him with quorum raft because
quorum wrath represents our ideologies
here ever he understands what it means
to truly be a king of Atlantis now in
this instance Aquaman really kind of
responds by saying well you're plunging
us into the dark ages you're setting us
back on massive amount of time and where
you would expect mera to be in his
corner and to say Aquaman is 100% right
I am loyal to my husband while she is
she actually takes the opportunity to
say maybe this is our chance to leave
maybe is our chance to vacate Atlantis
to take off and do our
thing and this is huge because mirror
has usually always been in the corner of
Aquaman again there have been times
where they've had a rift and in fact
there was a time I believe when they
were divorced or they were separated
from one another and and Ron wouldn't go
as far as to say there were enemies
there wasn't a whole lot of love loss
there but with regards to to this
instance right now she's really just
kind of saying let's run away let's
leave let's walk away but for Aquaman
it's not that simple and that's why I
say when it comes to him versus the
deluge you really starting to get into
them into some gray areas here the
deluge are loyal to Atlantis Aquaman is
loyal to Atlantis what differs here are
their fundamental views on what
direction Atlantis should take the
deluge want to take things back to the
way they used to be we are 100%
completely and totally isolationist
unless there's maybe some kind of a
threat that would deign endanger the
earth and if that threat is not going to
endanger Atlantis directly then we don't
care what happens to the heroes in the
service world whereas Aquaman coming
into this but we face a litany of
threats
there's been multiple times one that
when the earth has been threatened and
like that would endanger Atlantis but
it's one of these things worse like the
response of really that you know that
the council and the deluge is but we
don't care if it does not directly
threaten Atlantis we don't want to have
anything to do with it let the service
world be the service world if it means
all the heroes on the surface die then
it means they all die that's their
problem not our problem but it's kind of
interesting because it's one of these
things Aquaman kind of looks to this you
know and to paraphrase you old saying
here when they came for this group I was
sunning when they came for that group i
wasäôt when they came for that group I
was silent when they came for me there
was no one to speak up and so that's
kind of the stance that Aquaman takes
here but again mera basically leaves she
says look okay fine I will be at the
Lighthouse if you need me but I think
the best course of action for us is to
walk away I think the best course of
action for us is to leave and so where
you end up having quorum wrath who's
basically you know on the precipice of
being appointed as a new king you've
also got Tula who is well really kind of
like the region of sorts in Aquaman
stead who also vacates I mean she was
essentially taken prisoner you know and
of course she escapes her bonds and
takes off to the surface and so it's
really a very small kind of a bare-bones
crew of people who are aligning
themselves with Aquaman or at least who
can ally themselves with Aquaman and so
in this moment you end up having Alcorn
where he basically says there's all
these forms of magic down here there's
all these various weapons and tools and
things like that that we could use why
has an Aquaman used them before and
where the initial response is because he
was weak because he was incapable the
reality of this is because he chose not
to because
if Atlantis you know if the various
governments of the world you know for
example you know that the u.s.
government was monitoring Atlantis and
saw them put you know basically
performing a series of acts that look
like formations of war they were treated
as war and that would become defensive
this in turn would put the Atlanteans on
defense and would ultimately culminate
in a war between the surface and the
Atlanteans and so it was one of these
things where people kind of look at
Aquaman and they say what you would
consider to be a an act of
non-aggression well you would consider
to be something that basically says look
guys we're not here to fight you
we as adel you see that as placating
weakness we see that as you basically
you know cow howling to the surface
world doing everything you can
ingratiating yourself before them saying
hey look we're not we're not a threat
you know it's basically rolling over and
showing your belly and so again it's
it's totally different ideologies each
one has merit but they're so intriguing
here because basically when the council
of elders begins to rule here and when
they sit down and they look at Aquaman
and they said we are here to to
basically judge your verdict where do
you stand on this and each continues to
stand firm and say I refuse to believe
that no truce can be found between us in
the service world I refuse to believe
that the bridge cannot be created here
then he's still considered to be someone
who does not have any interest of
Atlantis front and forward and so
ultimately he's al stood they basically
said you are no longer King here you are
out and again this is huge a man can
only be a ruler of two kingdoms before
one of them turns on before one of it
you know before the question is asked
which one of these do you choose and
that's why I say it answers it in a more
indirect route because Aquaman's
response is of course I choose Atlantis
but just because you've been living
things a certain way for so long doesn't
mean that you have to live that way to
the end of time and it makes sense just
because you believe something's true
doesn't mean it is true it just means
you believe it to be true if you don't
have facts to back it up then it's just
an opinion and opinions aren't really
relevant and so it's interesting in the
situation because he's kind of booted
and so of course quorum laughs basically
takes up the throne and in turn Aquaman
goes to leave because the truth is that
if he were to stay then he would be
taken prisoner but what this does is it
allows him to basically leave Atlantis
proper or at least try to leave Atlantis
proper and then figure out what to do
next
but of course quorum wrath essentially
just starts constructing this massive
barrier of sorts around Atlantis and
Aquaman is caught in a conflict you know
caught sort of you know intertwined in
this whole thing because we're miracies
this massive amount of light you know
emerge from the ocean is just kind of
like what in the hell's going on and
immediately takes over you know takes
off to go see Aquaman partly
try to figure out you know understand
what's happening ultimately the the
shell basically converges on the city
itself Aquaman's caught any skilled they
say it you know he's essentially killed
by Merck and that's what's so crazy
about this is because the in order for
the new king to be crowned the existing
king must fault
it has to be the eminent now ideally
they would basically take him and they
would make him a prisoner but with Alka
man trying to engineer his escape
everyone watching this essentially knows
that what would happen here at least it
seems like they know that what would
happen here is Aquaman would go out and
martial forces he would find various
individuals around Atlantis that are not
necessarily enshrined inside this this
hovering over the capital city and he
would find those who were still loyal to
him and what this could potentially do
is plunge Atlantis into a civil war and
so with him basically being killed it
seems to be the end of Aquaman like it's
literally the end of him entirely and so
what this does is hopefully it goes for
giving us an answer hopefully goes
forward and tells us what happens next
but it's a cool thing it's kind of a
cool thing to see like this story taking
this direction because in reality
Aquaman always kind of seemed to be
mundane to me but I'm looking at this
and I'm just like holy Aquaman's badass
so like let me know what you guys think
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]